les droits d'auteur sont de moins en
moins rémunérés depuis les modifications
apportées à la loi sur le droit d'auteur
en 2012 la redevance annuelle payée aux
auteurs et aux éditeurs a chuté de 50%
dans les universités du québec de près
de 20% dans les cégeps ailleurs au
canada les redevances perçues ont même
chuté de 80%
que se passe-t-il avec nous frédéric
couette directeur général de copibec qui
la société québécoise de gestion
collective des droits de reproduction
bonsoir alors il ya eu des changements
en 2012 qui ont été apportées qui ont
fait baisser les redevances versées par
les universités qu'est ce qui s'est
passé mais c'est exact effectivement en
2012 en fait il ya eu un projet de loi
qui a été adopté son gouvernement harper
et ce projet de loi introduit une
multitude exceptions notamment en faveur
des établissements d'enseignement et en
fait cette loi est transformée en un
véritable gruyère aujourd'hui donc elle
est pleine de trous qui permettent de
faire des reproductions sans payer les
droits d'auteur essence demander
l'autorisation
donc on parle de reproduction du
matériel utilisé par les étudiants dans
les universités exactement tout à fait
donc on reproduit beaucoup et
généralement il ya des redevances sur
les droits d'auteur qui sont versés
c'est le système qui est en place depuis
longtemps effectivement depuis plus de
20 ans les auteurs et des éditeurs sont
dotés de sociétés de gestion collective
comme copibec au québec et ce sont ces
organismes sans but lucratif qui gère
ces droits là et donc depuis 20 ans
c'est le système qui était en place qui
fonctionne est très très bien et c'est
ça en 2012 donc cette exception plus
particulièrement l'exception
d'utilisation équitable à des fins
d'éducation qui a été interprété très
largement par les universités surtout à
l'extérieur du québec mais qui a
entraîné cette baisse excessive des
redevances donc on demandait - aux
universités ou en tout cas on demande
aux universités de verser moindre
redevance
en fait c'est pas qu'on leur demande de
verser moins de relance et qu'elle exige
de hercé moins de redevances acquis aux
aiguilles auprès de la société de
gestion collective que pi beck qui
représente les auteurs et les éditeurs
bon et pourquoi c'est comme ça pourquoi
on a décidé d'adopter ces modifications
là c'était quoi l'objectif de faire ça
c'est une excellente question voyez-vous
par ce qui est effectivement quand on
parle avec
avec le gouvernement ce qu'on nous dit
où avec les fonctionnaires ce qu'on nous
disait que l'objectif n'était pas celui
d'aboutir à un non paiement des
redevances
l'objectif était un objectif de
clarification de la législation
clarification de la loi et de la porte
et l'utilisation équitable mais que les
redevances devaient continuer d'être
payés aux sociétés de gestion collective
or ce n'est pas le cas du tout c'est pas
le cas on a interprété la loi permet une
interprétation
oui les universités ont décidé d'adopter
une interprétation très très large de la
loi parce qu'elle est très imprécise en
parle d'utilisation équitable à des fins
d'éducation sans aucune précision et
donc du coup elles ont interprété cette
loi de manière très extensive se
permettant ainsi de faire des
reproductions qui avant tomber dans le
cas des licences donc les universités se
trouve à moins rémunérés les droits
d'auteurs des auteurs et les versements
qui doivent être faits aux auteurs et
aux éditeurs tout cas c'est alors le mot
temps annuel par étudiant en 2012
c'était 25 $ 50
oui par reproduction non 25 $ 50 par
étudiant à temps complet par année
parfait et ça a été divisé par deux
quasiment oui on est à 13 dollars 50
aujourd'hui par étudiant à temps complet
par un niveau universitaire mais ça
c'est au québec ailleurs au canada ses
clients au canada c'est pire
effectivement les universités les
collèges à l'extérieur du cadre du
québec dans le reste du canada ont
décidé de ne plus payer les redevances
du tout donc il me verse plus de
redevances à la société de gestion
collective access copyright qui est
l'homologue de copibec pour le reste du
canada et les ministères l'éducation
quant à aux primaires secondaires
poursuivre access copyright parce qu'ils
refusent de payer ils demandent que des
sommes qui auraient été trop perçus
selon eux leur soit rendue quels sont
les effets sur les hauteurs sur les
hipsters les effets sur les auteurs et
les éditeurs sont assez son passé
dramatique parce que au niveau des
auteurs on parle d'un revenu médian de
3000 $ par année ce sont les données qui
avait été
sorti par l'inec l'union nationale des
qui l'union des écrivains et des
écrivaines québécoise par bonds est donc
bien évident ce sont des revenus qui
sont pas énormes alors lorsque vous
diminue encore ces revenus là parce que
les redevances de copibec diminue
d'année en année bien le temps vous
pouvez consacrer à l'écriture diminue
bien évidemment vous devez aller
chercher des revenus afin de subvenir à
vos besoins
ailleurs alors vous n'avez plus le temps
d'écrire et l'écriture fini par devenir
un hobby et non plus une profession est
donc le gouvernement fédéral doit se
pencher sur la question des droits
d'auteur prochainement en fait se penche
sur cette question depuis plusieurs
années mais doit déposer un projet de
loi
peut-être en 2020 qui sait vous demandez
quoi au gouvernement fédéral
on sait effectivement qu'il va y avoir
un projet l'autre révision est ce que
nous on demande c'est qu'effectivement
la loi sur le droit d'auteur l'exception
d'utilisation équitable bien être limité
qu'elles soient limitées
nous on a une société de gestion
collective qui est un organisme sans but
lucratif créée par les auteurs et les
éditeurs qui fonctionne à parité cet
organisme l' offre des licences depuis
des années un coût très raisonnable
alors à partir d'une licence qui est
offert par une société de gestion
collectif qui est offert par copibec eh
bien il faut que l'exception
d'utilisation équitable à des fins
d'éducation ne s'applique plus parce
qu'il ya un système qui permet à la fois
de conjuguer rémunération des auteurs et
des éditeurs et facilité d'accès pour
les établissements d'enseignement
je trouve ça un petit peu complexe ce
que vous voulez dans le fond c'est qu'on
revienne aux redevances qui avait avant
les modifications de 2012
absolument ce qu'on veut c'est être en
mesure de négocier des redevances qui
sont véritablement représentatif de la
valeur des leurs et est ce que le
gouverneur ces gouvernements du canada
le nouveau ministre du patrimoine qui va
s'occuper de ça c'est steven guilbeault
est ce que le gouvernement du québec
peut faire quelque chose
le gouvernement du québec peut faire
deux choses le gouvernement du québec
peut continuer de soutenir la
rémunération des auteurs et
l'acquisition des licences par les
établissements d'enseignement dont
directement à travers le ministère de
l'éducation mais aussi en soutenant le
processus de négociation avec les
universités et les cégeps de façon en ce
moment
rémunération qu'ils soient correctes et
d'autre part il peut aussi jouer un rôle
d'influencé rôle de modèle pour le reste
du canada
oui bon on verra si vos demandes et se
sont entendus bien sûr puis on va
surveiller la révision de la loi sur le
droit d'auteur faire de frédéric watts
merci merci beaucoup merci bien